hey guys this is andrew from
tradingsensors.com i'm a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong and i've been working for several
big investment banks like hsbc or
commerce bank
and i've just started to make youtube
videos because guys i want to
pass the knowledge and i want to share
with you my experience
about technical analysis about what is
working and what is not working
so if you want to understand the
different tools that pro traders are
using and the different
techniques that exist to make money on
the markets you are in the right place
so today i want to keep talking about
those penny stocks
so i want to do pgen and dds which for
me are very beautiful targets for the
relatives
let's get into it
[Music]
so let's start with pgen so same thing
guys
if you watch my previous videos i'm
actually checking the market
capitalization and the short interest
so basically i found my stocks you know
i just hang out on those forums wall
street bets
i go on twitter and i check you know the
different stocks you know for example
like this guy is talking about nyld i
did this one it's not nice
and you know i basically do them one by
one and i check the information and
the way i define my targets i want a
small market cap
i want a big short interest and and then
i check if i have
a good signals on my chart so pgen
1.7 billion usd of market capitalization
which is
low and 20 of short interest it's not
that big
compared for example to tds dds that has
77
but we still have a lot of short
interest for example amc when it started
to go
much higher it was 25 30 so it's enough
all right
let's look at the technicals so this is
a daily chart
and you can see that same thing as for
every
stock that i'm analyzing here the
earnings are
look very bad the stock dropped heavily
from you know it lost like 898
of its uh total value and now it looks
like we have some bullish signals so the
question is is it the right time to buy
guys here i see a beautiful breakout and
retesting the breakout
so as you you saw on all the different
stuff and the last guys
this is the nice situation you have a
breakout you don't buy it you wait for
the retest you buy the re-test you put a
stop-loss just below
and here we almost have a double signal
all right so if i do this upward
swapping trend line
it gives me a bang level around so for
now it's gonna be six
but in mid-march it's gonna be seven so
if mid-march
the stock comes back to seven so right
now it's trading at 850.
guys it's still a nice level to buy at
50 but if
mid-march you see it at 7 or 750
then you have a double uh support level
this one
and this one so i showed you again guys
i connect the highs
here all right and i check if after the
breakout
there was a nice retest here you can see
that it has been broken
let me zoom in a little bit so you see
better has been broken but not long
and then we are just you know drifting
here so i think we might
end up here around uh some mid-march
around seven or something like this
and then guys you can put easily a
buying signal here but buying level here
and a stop-loss just below so you can
lose
if you buy or let's say at 740 and
you stop loss at 650 you have 13
of maximum loss and guys what are the
targets
same thing i try to see what i have a
lot of consolidation
here i have one two three here i have
the maximum so of course
it's a resistance and then guys bam
160
and the next one 800 guys so the risk we
would
ratios of this stuff is amazing so
if you are looking for this kind of
trades this is a client
this is one where the stock is behaving
very well uh technically speaking
i think that a lot of hedge funds and
professional traders are involved in
here and they're gonna help you
uh to maintain this behavior clean for
the coming
weeks days because they're gonna all
take the same decisions together that's
why
a stock is clean is where when you have
enough people
that you know trade in the same way
using the same techniques
uh that make that the stock price action
is actually predictable
all right guys so this is a nice client
let's do the next one
it's a beautiful client as well so once
again let's go
to the earnings so here the earnings are
going higher maybe
for this reason it's not a target
anymore for the hedge funds
but i mean to me it's better to buy
something that has earnings that you
know look
good so let's look at the short interest
yes 77
so i don't know why there is so much uh
short interest on the stuff because
technically it looks good the earnings
are going higher so
maybe the costs are very high i don't
know maybe you know the management is
not good
they must have some reasons all right
otherwise there wouldn't be that much
short interest
so let's kind of you know assume that
this stock is weak
otherwise it wouldn't be a target for
hedge funds that are shorting it
but what i see is that we can create
they can be a short squeeze
uh the market cap is a very low once
again guys
this means that if all the money goes
together in it
uh it's going to be tough for the uh the
guys that are showing
it to hold their short position because
of the maximum loss they can have on a
single strategy this is how it's working
in hedge funds
they cannot lose too much money on one
strategy so if they do they cut it all
right
okay let's go back to the technicals and
so here guys
downward sloping trend line broken
okay so you don't want to buy the
breakout once again
you wait for the retest and here guys we
are retesting it right so around 75 so
we're
right now at 81 and if you want to even
do something more secure
you just do like this and you wait for
the crossover
all right so it might never happen but
guys we have a lot of stocks
don't you know put your money in in a
stock where the signals are not perfect
here the signal would be perfect if we
reach uh 70
in may right then you would have a
double support level
which makes it like more likely to go
higher and then the resistance level is
at 140.
so here as you can see there is not that
much
uh you know upside because the maximum
price of the stock was not that high
so there is a lot of downside on the
other hand uh
because as you can see it didn't lose
that much so be very careful use a tight
stop loss on the stuff guys uh
it's uh you know it's something that can
go much much lower
if we go to the recent low it's losing
70
guys so just you know be careful don't
put too much money into this if you want
to invest and be very careful guys all
right so that's it for me
coming soon bl nk and sig
sig i see a beautiful buying signal so
if you guys want to know more about how
i do my analysis
and about the other stuff that i see uh
in this list
just click on the subscribe button and
the like button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to show that's you guys
you